-Hello, everyone,
I´m Seth Meyers,
the series finale
of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
aired earlier tonight,
and now we´re so happy
to be joined
by the show´s incredible cast.
Dirk Blocker,
Joel McKinnon Miller,
Stephanie Beatriz,
Andre Braugher,
Andy Samberg,
Melissa Fumero,
Joe Lo Truglio
and co-creator
and showrunner Dan Goor.
Thank you all for being here.
Congratulations on
the amazing finale,
the amazing accomplishment
of so many seasons.
I want to start by a quick shout
out to those who aren´t here.
Terry Crews
can not be with us tonight.
We did want to make sure
his presence was felt.
We do have a cut out Terry,
and we´re very happy
with the technology
that we´ve used
to make his pecs go.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, really good.
[ Laughter ]
Really good.
And that´s all computers.
It looked like a crew guy
ran behind him,
but that´s all...
-Broke the bank on the seats.
-Yeah, and we also --
Chelsea Peretti
cannot be here, but she did --
she sent a video.
So let´s take a look
at what Chelsea has to say.
-♫ My bags were packed ♫
♫ I was ready to go ♫
♫ Jordan´s assistant
was going to take me ♫
♫ He was at the door ♫
♫ And then my son started
puking for five hours ♫
♫ He´s better now,
but I missed the trip ♫
♫ I bought a dress where
the back won´t zip ♫
♫ The website said size down
because it runs large ♫
♫ Not that large ♫
♫ I´m not leaving
on a jet plane ♫
♫ I´m stuck in my [bleep]
house again ♫
[ Laughter ]
Well, good luck, everyone.
Thanks for having me
in this capacity.
[ Laughter ]
-They get a bomb shelter,
I think.
-What a voice.
-What a beautiful voice.
-I like that she didn´t let
television
slow down her -- her pace.
She didn´t speed it up for us.
-No, and we gave her --
She was like,
"How long should it be?"
And we said, "10 seconds,
not a second more."
She really took advantage.
-But I should milk it, though?
-So I think these, you know,
obviously finales
are incredibly emotional.
Oftentimes, you see, you know,
other shows that are beloved.
You see films
of the final table read.
What was it like for you guys?
And was it hamstrung
because of this crazy era
we´re living through?
-Well, it was quite hamstrung.
It was on Zoom.
-So, that was the final
table read was on Zoom.
-Last day together we were
in the middle of shooting
when we did it, so we were all
in our dressing rooms on Zoom.
So you could like hear people
laughing across the hall
and stuff.
But you know, inevitably someone
has like a terrible delay
and it ruins it.
I feel like, Joe, didn´t you
have like a major problem?
-I had a major technical issue
with my computer
in that it kept dropping out,
so we had to swap out a laptop
with a -- with like one of
the wardrobe assistants,
came in and I was -- I was
in a bit of a panic
because it seemed to happen only
on Charles Boyle´s line.
[ Laughter ]
-And it froze on your face
and you were like...
[ Laughter ]
Like, so upset about it.
-Pure terror, I´m sure.
-I feel like we all heard you
yelling in the hallway, right?
[Bleep]
-It´s out!
We got a laptop?!
-It´s the finale!
I want to be emotional.
-I was -- I was --
-Cold sweats.
-It sounded --
it seemed to me
like you were just making
an acting choice,
like a really long pause.
-Boyle just flips out.
-Yeah.
-Dan, as like somebody
who obviously knows,
like obviously put all this time
into writing the finale,
you know this is, you know,
the final thing
everybody´s going to see,
when you watch like
a terrible, tech-laden
you know,
errors-laden Zoom read through,
do you least think there´s
going to be so much better
when it´s on TV?
-No.
Was instantly so depressed.
I-I -- but also,
it should be said,
with the sole exception
of Charles Boyle
not really doing well,
it was not
that much of a disaster.
-That´s right.
-And by not doing well, I mean,
just technically.
You know, I´m constantly
in a fetal position,
pulling my hair out
and convinced
that we´ve destroyed
the legacy of the show.
-Have you unfolded now
that the finale is there?
Do you feel like
you´re finally non-fetal again?
-I am semi non-fetal.
Yeah, I´m not.
I´m not fetal.
-That´s really exciting, man.
-That´s hot.
That´s hot look for you.
-Thank you.
-You guys had, I mean,
almost all of you
had really emotional moments
in the finale.
You guys had an intimate moment
Are those moments --
does Dan writes
specifically what he wants?
Or do you guys, sometimes
as actors, find your own way?
-Anytime there is a Jake and Amy
kiss on the show,
Dan requests that it be tender.
And it´s the worst,
and he knows we hate it.
-Hate it so much.
-He goes, "Just make sure
it´s really tender."
I´m like, "I want to quit
the show So bad right now."
Like, you´re trying to act good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-As a fan of the show,
I want what the other fans want,
which is a kiss that is tender.
-[Sighs]
-And I put that in the stage
directions every single time.
-I wish they didn´t push it
so hard in the promos
like, "Tonight on
Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
things get tender."
-Yeah.
-Really a problem.
-I feel like Dan paid
someone off at promo.
-Do you have -- do you have
the sort of COVID police
on those intimate moments?
-Well, we hadn´t until
this last year, of course.
But, yeah, we weren´t
planning on doing one.
But it was actually...
How did it go down?
Dan wanted to add it on set.
He did say he wanted it to be
tender, if anyone´s wondering.
But we weren´t --
we thought we couldn´t do it.
And then he went
to the COVID safety specialist.
-Yeah, I said -- because
we had written the scene,
there´s a very emotional scene
between the two of them.
They are fantastic in it,
and it felt so strange
that we hadn´t written
that they should kiss.
And I said, "Can we add a kiss?"
And the director was like,
absolutely not. COVID.
They cannot kiss.
If they kiss,
they have to both --
We have to get it approved
in advance,
they have to rapid test
and they have to mouthwash
immediately beforehand.
Rinse with Listerine,
like a powerful Listerine,
more powerful than normal.
-Like Glycerin.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Okay."
And all of a sudden,
the COVID guy,
Sean walked up and he said,
"They can kiss."
And we were like, it´s a go,
and they kissed,
it was tender.
-And then it was
a pretty massive
breakout, right?
You guys had to shut it down.
-Yeah.
-For sure.
Took down the whole lot.
It spread to other shows.
It was [bleep] up.
-First case of Delta in L.A.
[ Laughter ]
-Andre, we´ve talked
before on the show.
The funniest thing
that Andy ever told me
was that he was going to be
in a television show with you.
-Yes, it was funny to me, too.
-Yeah, it was funny
to you, too. I can only imagine
how funny it was for you.
I was actually thinking about
this when the the late great
Ed Asner passed away
because he played Lou Grant
as his comedy character,
and then he played it
as a dramatic character.
And obviously, you played a
different character on this show
than you did on homicide,
but there was
a dramatic police show
and now this comedy police show.
Do you feel like this is a sort
of perfect bookend to these --
these two acts in your career?
-I do feel that way
in a certain way.
You know,
I´d grown tired of playing cops.
You know what I mean?
I don´t.
My wife says,
you´re the perfect cop
and I don´t see
what she´s talking about.
But -- but I´m often cast
in that way.
And this was
the perfect opportunity
to -- to spin it
in a certain way, you know,
and to explore
something different.
And -- and exactly
as I had hoped,
it was transformational.
I mean,
in terms of my career,
in terms of my --
my acting skill,
in terms of my joy, you know,
in front of the camera.
So it´s been a great experience,
you know?
-And you know the other thing
that was a very famous chapter
of this show
was that it was canceled
and then sort of brought back
by the fans.
Was it exciting to go out
on your own terms this time?
-It was amazing.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I think we all really
feel
exceptionally proud of the work
that we did this last season.
And like with all the strange
challenges and the, like,
all of the challenges,
the writing challenges,
the acting challenges,
the crew challenges,
but it felt really,
I don´t know.
Felt, like you said,
joyful.
It felt really joyful the way
that we finished it.
-Well, it felt that way
to watch as well.
We´ll be right back with more
from the cast
of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
But first,
Lin-Manuel Miranda´s
musical take on the
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine" theme song.
♫ Brooklyn Nine-Nine ♫
♫ Nine-Nine ♫
♫ Everyone who sees this show ♫
♫ Agrees it rocks ♫
♫ It´s on NBC ♫
♫ ´Cause it´s too good
for Fox ♫
♫ Brooklyn Nine-Nine ♫
♫ Sad to see you go ♫
♫ You´re a good show ♫
♫ Andre Braugher rules ♫
I love you.
-Welcome back.
We are here with the wonderful
cast of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
Dan, I´m wondering how you came
up with the idea for the show
and how you first
approached Andy with the pitch.
-So I used to work on
"Parks and Recreation"
with the wonderful Mike Schur,
who you are very familiar with.
-Yes.
-And I was there for five years,
and we decided we wanted
to create a show together.
So we had this idea
and we were trying to figure out
who the perfect
lead actor would be.
And then Andy, it turns out,
had just left
"Saturday Night Live"
and he was in Los Angeles.
So Mike and I in what is
the most Hollywood experience
I´ve ever had,
went to the Villa
that Andy and Lonely Island
we´re renting.
-That´s right.
-A villa...
[ Laughter ]
in order to record
their third album.
-I think I was at that villa.
Was I at that villa?
-You definitely visited
said villa.
-Yeah.
-It was
a real Hollywood villa.
-Oh, yes.
So, where did you take
this meeting?
At the pool?
Where did you?
-It was poolside.
I brought Mike and Dan
out by the pool.
We had refreshments.
They pitched me on the show.
The character,
his name was Jake.
-I´m so grossed out right now.
-Why
-Did you take a lot of calls
during the meeting?
-I took many calls
during the meeting.
All fake.
-You´re so good at faking calls.
Do one --fake one
of your Hollywood calls?
-Sorry, one sec, Seth.
Hello.
Oh, hi, Lorne.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
Yes, Seth is bombing.
Yeah.
Like he´s never
done it before.
It´s crazy.
Alright, see you at [indistinct]
[ Laughter ]
-Very good.
-Thanks.
-I mean, I believe it.
If I didn´t know,
I´d believe it.
So, Joel and Dirk, you guys
played a Hitchcock and Scully,
and these were characters
that grew, I think,
beyond what any of us
would have hoped over the years.
Did you have a favorite
storyline to play of the many
that you were given
over the years?
-Well, I would probably say
the episode
where that resulted in us
having a battle
of the penis punch, 69.
-Yeah,
-It was probably one of them.
-Yeah.
-There are so many, really.
-Yeah, but that´s
an actor´s dream.
-Yeah, it was, indeed.
And and there was no COVID
at the time.
So we were able to, you know...
-Really get in there.
[ Laughter ]
-And by that, you mean
punch each other´s penises.
-Yeah, correct.
-That´s the acting.
It´s an actor.
-Sure.
-Yeah, I love thinking about
anyone watching this
that hasn´t seen the show
And that´s the first
episode-specific reference.
-Who here, and other people can
answer for other actors up here,
who is the most or the least
like the character
they play on the show?
-Least as easy.
-Yeah, I´d Stephanie.
-Stephanie.
-[ High-pitched ] It´s me.
It´s me everybody.
I´m the most different.
[ Laughs ]
-When you were on --
Stephanie, I will say when
you were on this show
as a guest, that was
the feedback online from people.
-Jarring.
-Yeah.
-People don´t like it.
They want me to be Rosa
in real life.
They are very upset
that I´m not.
-They are definitely --
they´re thrown
to the fact that they thought
when you were here,
you were doing a character.
-Yeah.
-Which is a comp --
It´s a highest compliment
I could have as an actor,
which is like,
I don´t like
your real personality.
I like your fake
character personality
that I´ve known for eight years.
But the real, you can suck it.
It´s nice.
-It´s really nice.
Could you give us a little Rosa?
-No, absolutely not.
-That was it.
[ Laughter ]
Most like?
I mean, he´s not -- his --
he´s not here,
but Terry is pretty similar.
I mean, he is essentially here
when you look at the tech.
-Yeah.
Can we do the tech again?
-It´s the scale, I believe.
-Yeah, see, it´s basically
like Terry´s here.
Yeah, that´s all --
That´s like Wi-Fi enabled.
That´s a bluetooth.
-Bluetooth is control that.
-That´s running through
firmware.
-Does anyone here --
Obviously,
that cardboard cut out
is doing an
incredible impression of Terry.
Does anyone here do impressions
of other people on the show?
I mean, everyone kind
of does an Andre.
-Okay. Who´s got the best
Andre in the house?
-Melissa,
-Wow.
-Totally threw her
under the bus.
-You do an Andre.
You start it off.
-Good morning.
Right?
I´ve done it on the show,
though, because Jake does it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Okay, everyone do your Andre
at the same time, though.
Ready, three, two, one.
[ All imitating Andre Braugher ]
-And that my friend
is good television.
[ Laughter ]
-I´m glad you guys
didn´t over rehearse that
because it felt --
I know you´re not going
to believe it --
that felt like the first time.
-Yeah, yeah.
I would sometimes feel
like this question --
Did anybody here
take anything when they left
the set for the last time?
-Like drugs?
-Yeah, did you like...
-Oh,oh, take things from.
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Yeah,
maybe some Ambien."
-I did.
I had a lot of props
that I worked with all the time,
and I´m really having
a hard time stopping,
you know, with props.
So I brought my selfie stick
tonight.
-But not your phone?
-Well, I don´t have a phone.
-Oh, you just have the stick.
-Very Scully-like.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, I wanted to do a selfie
with all of us with Seth.
-Yeah.
-But I got to find a phone.
-You can always just use it
as a back scratcher.
-Thank you.
-We -- we have
another special message
from somebody
who´s been on the show.
We´ll be right back with more
with the cast
of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
and taking us out
is "Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
guest star Craig Robinson.
-♫ Yeah ♫
♫ Turn my headphones up ♫
♫ Come on, everybody ♫
♫ Let´s go solve some crimes ♫
♫ Crimes in New York City ♫
♫ And other areas ♫
♫ Brooklyn Nine-Nine ♫
♫ Pontiac bandit ♫
-Welcome back.
We´re here with the cast
of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
Joe, your character
was obsessed
with the actor
Dianne Wiest.
-Yes.
-Where did this come from?
-Dan Goor and the writers.
I -- I, you know, I don´t --
I´m not quite sure the obsession
with that with Dianne Wiest.
-Yeah, it´s a pretty
fun character trait.
-I think that Charles
very much enjoys theatrics
and -- and great actors.
musicals,
and I think Dianne Wiest
encompasses
all of those things.
-Yeah. Well, that´s a really
nice message for her,
and we actually have
a message from her.
-Wait a minute.
-No, sir.
-Hi, I´m Dianne Wiest,
and I would just like to say
congratulations
on your show,
on your run.
And I like to say
especially to Charles Boyle,
that you can wash
my hair any day,
and I will wash your hair
right back any day.
Thank you. Bye.
-Incredible.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you for mentioning me.
Bye.
-Oh, my God.
-I´m crying.
I´m -- I´m floored.
I´m -- this is --
this is incredible.
How did you...
-Yeah.
-What -- what -- how?
-She reached out to us.
[ Laughter ]
She heard you were coming
and she was like,
"Can I shoot something
on my iPhone and send it out?"
I was like, "Yeah."
She was like, "You can guarantee
Joe will see it?"
We said, "Absolutely."
That´s incredible.
I am quite touched by that.
That´s amazing.
-And it´s really nice
when you find out collectively
that Dianne Wiest has
a great sense of humor.
-Yes.
-I also love that she
introduced
herself at the top.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, we know, Dianne.
You´re the best.
-Hey, we reached out to people
on Twitter.
These are some,
some cast questions.
The first ones from LV824.
"Would the cast be open
to the idea of getting
a tattoo like the ´Avengers´
cast did to commemorate
their eight years together?
If so,
what would the tattoo be?"
-Ooh.
-I think of it as more
is what the cast
of "Lord of the Rings" did.
-Okay.
-But, you know,
for the youngsters,
I guess "Avengers."
[ Laughter ]
Obviously, I´m against it
because I want to be buried
in a Jewish cemetery.
It´s very important to me,
but...
-I´m trying to think of which
is cooler in your answer so far.
That part or the like,
"I´m a Lord of the Rings guy."
[ Laughter ]
-I don´t know.
I mean, I feel like some of us
do already have tats.
-Mm-hmm.
Some don´t.
-What would it be, though,
if you got it?
-What would it be?
-Oh, I think I know
what it would be.
It would be Holt´s tattoo.
Holt´s tattoo.
-Yeah.
-Kevin.
-Holt´s.
-Oh, and you got that for real?
-Oh, yeah.
Should I...
Nah.
-Andre is a method actor.
-We´re on late.
We´re not on that late.
-Little tramp stamp.
-Alright, guys.
Here´s another one.
"If you could meet
your character,
what do you think would be
the first thing
they would think of you,
You, the person,
without knowing you play them?"
-It´s a very.
really, Zen question.
-Yeah, Rosa would think I suck.
-Yeah.
-She should straight up
say it to my face.
-Really?
-100 percent.
And then then
we´d become friends
because she´s a real softy.
-Eventually, you wear her down.
-Yeah.
-Three seasons.
In three seasons
after she met you,
you´d be friends.
-That´s right. That´s it.
Not right away.
Right away, you suck,
immediately.
-Spin off show.
-Spin off.
-Amy -- I don´t know
if Amy would like me.
Maybe be should would.
I don´t if I would like Amy.
She feels like she´d be
a lot of energy,
a high maintenance friend.
-I feel like Jake
would be pretty hyped.
-He´d be like,
"You´re Andy Samberg."
Dude.
-"Lord of The Rings."
[ Laughter ]
"Lord of the Rings"
through the cemetery.
[ Laughter ]
-He´d watch this.
He´s a big fan
of this episode?
-Well, I mean,
he watches this show.
-Right. So...
[ Laughter ]
-He´s like, "What´s Seth Meyers
like in real life?"
-Dude, Lin-Manuel
did that thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, guys.
This is -- I like this question.
"If they had gotten
Bruce Willis,
did the writers have a plan
for what they would
do with him and what was it?"
-Dan?
-Well, there are always
pitches from a writer´s room
that are like
the whole "Nine-Nine"
is called out on a on a big case
and then he walks in
and he´s like,
"Hey, is there anyone here?
No, I guess not."
And then he walks out,
you know, like a total [bleep]
-Fairly. That would have
made it fairly easy.
-Yes, it would have.
-I always just assumed
he would be like,
Jake sees him on the street,
loses his mind, right?
He´s like, Hey, how you doing
good kid or something?
-I think that´s a good way
of looking at it.
Okay, so these are -- this one
is from notandysamberg1
is the name
of this Twitter account.
-Okay.
- I´m just going to
come right out and say
I think you wrote this.
-We´ll see.
-"This is actually a question
for Seth
about ´Brooklyn Nine-Nine.´
Seth, would you agree
that ´Brooklyn Nine-Nine´
is a great show
and also that your dog Frisbee
is another ugly piece of [bleep]
that looks like a rat skeleton
that was puked up
by an acid monster?"
[ Laughter ]
Right.
And you think I wrote that?
-I do.
I think that you sort
of pointed towards yourself
by making the fake account
notandysamberg.
-The handle says it´s not me.
-Alright.
-By the way,
notandysamberg was taken.
I had to get 1.
[ Laughter ]
There´s still out there
not -- not me.
-Beat you to the punch.
-Snatched it up.
-A lot of people not you,
don´t feel bad.
Finishing second´s great.
Alright, so I do --
I want to take a minute.
Obviously, I know
where you land on this.
I would like to ask the entire
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
cast,
will go down from beginning,
Is Frisbee a good dog
or bad dog.
Starting with you.
-Oh, Frisbee´s a good dog.
-Very good dog.
-Good dog.
-Great dog.
Andy´s always wrong.
-Ehh.
[ Laughter ]
-And, Andy, final thoughts.
-Steaming hot pile of [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-We´ll be right back with more
from the cast
of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
but first, here´s Fred Armisen.
-I always thought
that the lyrics
to the "Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
theme were...
♫ It´s the game of thrones ♫
♫ White walkers
are coming home ♫
♫ Lannisters on the phone ♫
♫ You know nothing Jon Snow ♫
♫ Jake Peralta
likes to hang in Westeros ♫
♫ It´s the kind of thing
you see on HBO ♫
♫ It´s a game of thrones ♫
[ Laughter ]
-I want to thank my guest
Dirk Blocker,
Joel McKinnon Miller,
Stephanie Beatriz,
Andre Braugher,
Andy Samberg,
Melissa Fumero,
Joe Lo Truglio and Dan Goor.
I also want to thank
Jose Medeles and the 8G band.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫♫